a lot examines with us no former
Scottish first Minister hello how much
Advance warning were you given or none
at all but I suspect was very few people
were were told in advance
um what does her Legacy look like
well I mean Nicholas biggest political
Talent was as a communicator I mean she
was a superior political communicator
and that was showing up in the pandemic
you know if there was pretty clear
messaging from Scotland and much less
clear messaging from Downing Street so I
think that was her I would say biggest
achievement also winning elections some
importations are meant to win elections
and Nicola was very good at winning
elections I'd say these were her two
bigger chickens what was there on doing
I don't I don't know I I mean there's a
multitude of problems just now uh in
terms of policy delivery in Scotland not
not just the gender recognition bill but
the you know things like non-delivery of
the A9 which is a huge project and and
Scotland the the mounting problems and
health and and education
alarming difficulty over a deposit the
turn scheme but but you know none of
these things are things that you don't
normally cope with I mean you know
governing is quite difficult and
normally when you come up against a
problem you you find another way you
change direction you resolve these
clearly decks and especially is since
her policy was that to have a de facto
referendum next year in the general
election you would think you know that
would be your moment you die that win or
lose it it would be a moment for uh for
stepping down so I think it's a surprise
to most people it's certainly a surprise
to me so why do you think now then
I don't know I mean that's only a
question that's the gender recognition
issue no I don't think it's a single
issue I mean I think I was a a major
misstamp and certainly the you know the
Scottish press Corps and the the London
press go or on her case because it was
legislation which quite easily had you
could detect flaws in it to say the very
least and the alienated many women's
campaigners you know who saw it as a
threat to the Single Sex spaces so it's
a big big misstep but you think you know
what you would do there is you'd resolve
it you would come to a compromise with
the secretary state for Scotland you
would accept the rebel amendments from
the SNP back benches and you dissolving
that that's what you normally do when
you come up against a political problem
it was causing a great deal of damage
but I I can't see that as a a single
explanation and the Supreme Court
decision as well that went against her
um do you think it would ever have been
possible for her to deliver Independence
so she said it was her life's work well
you see the the Supreme Court uh going
to the Supreme Court and asking for that
advice was inexplicable as a as a
political strategy I mean you know the
the Supreme Court of the United Kingdom
it says that on the 10th you know the
Supreme Court United Kingdom is not the
sort of institution which guides you
through ways to dissolve the United
Kingdom
so many people including myself thought
that was extraordinary I mean what you
do if you're running up against a
roadblock if you're an old advocate well
firstly you shouldn't have that position
because you'd make sure that it wasn't
going to happen but then you'd have your
own referendum on a question that would
be with incompetence so going to Supreme
Court was a great puzzle but don't you
say we're going over de facto referendum
that's gonna and what the puzzle is is
why isn't that being seen through so
that's one of the big questions for the
future the other big question there's no
obvious success
today because I've been there you know
I've been at that point the resignation
but Nicola was the obvious successor
back in 2014 know you've got a field of
people who were any one of
a number it could emerge as I said when
I hope people emerges as that winner
chooses to do two things one is to
reunite the national movement and
perhaps do a bit more about separating
the business of government which is
difficult which is causes great
controversy from the the cause of
Independence perhaps for Underpants
convention because you know back in 2014
there was an SMP government which you
know was General regarded is doing very
well but there was also an independence
YES Movement which was larger than the
SMP and large on the SMP government and
when the government gets into trouble as
it's been doing recently that's when if
you don't separate the two it damages
the the yes the independence movement as
well but you fell out badly didn't you a
couple of years ago and she no longer
had that air cover from you do you think
that that was one of you know the first
nail in the coffin well I I'm obviously
I the the nickel I led you back in 2014
and there's Dr 16 didn't you well yeah
I'll go right back to 1992 I think was
our first first election and I didn't
recognize that that same person in the
last few years but you know falling out
with me uh is not a reason for for
resignation uh I mean you know she's
done and that happened two or three
years back the reason for vaccination
must lie elsewhere we've had the
protection of of you in that a lot of
people
um in Scotland still feel that you are
you know a valued politician well maybe
perhaps let's broaden it away from me if
if you have for this many people
proposing not not just me you have an
independence convention to lead the yes
the independence movement and your bill
to taken advice and a contribution wider
than the SNP government now that would
be a strength not just any contribution
I can make but others can make as well
and Nicola was a quite a narrowly
focused decision-making up much more
narrower than I was I mean I used to
listen to all sorts of people just to
test ideas that wasn't Nicholas let's be
clear about it though are you saying
with Nicholas sturgeon gone you see the
possibility to merge your party back
with the SNP well what I think Adam
would be more likely it would be to have
the independence convention that people
within the SMP have been calling for
which one stays Nicola agreed with and
people out with the SMP whereby the
leadership of the independence campaign
would be comprised of a number of
political parties and cross-party and
non-party organizations now that's quite
difficult to do if you can find the
independence movement to government now
that's something we didn't do in 2014 I
should remember there was this
multifarious YES Movement which went far
beyond the SMP government it was only
when we had that movement that you saw
the takeoff professor of the independent
support from roughly 30 to 45. I mean I
hear what you're saying I remember 2014
but what you appear to be saying is get
on with government and put almost the
independence campaign not just
separately but to one side I mean a a
delay in when the choice may come out
not not delay at all much more likely
because the case for Independence can
suffer from the day-to-day difficulties
of government and then you know there's
an articulated case for Scottish
independence to be made which is beyond
the exigences of day-to-day governance
of Scotland now it helps obviously the
case for Independence if that bit's
going well but when that bit runs into
trouble as it has been recently you've
got to make sure that the fundamental
case for Independence isn't damaged it's
not I mean on the country not not delay
in the country I think that would help
to to accelerate I mean you can't win
independence unless you convince a
steady majority of people it's a good
idea and you can't do that unless you're
campaigning on the independence issue
and that can get burdened by being
bogged down
I was chatting to one of my women to
contacts this morning and they said it's
a good day for unionism
well well we'll have to see I mean you
know that's uh I've heard that line
before somehow you know that was it was
always going to be a great day for
unionism this would happen that would
happen the next thing would happen but
if it was great yes I do actually
because of the the steady
aspect of the last generation of
Scottish Politics the underlying
position has been the growth of support
for for Independence and hopefully we'll
see now the broadening of that to
Independence base beyond the air
something so let me put it a different
way are we closer or further away to
Scottish independence today given that
Nicholas sturgeon's resigned well it
depends to emerges as the first Minister
and SMP leader oh yeah
give us who who use it I mean I'll give
you four names Kate Forbes Hamza Yousef
John Swinney Angus Robertson and Swinney
I I think it'll uh match for us if
you're obviously not a fan but no no I
was surprised I can't I would I would
say it's more likely to be somebody from
the the new generation than the the
previous Nicola Generations but you know
Kate Forbes is leading well I mean she
certainly
she certainly have had the the advantage
of distance from some of the
government's recent difficulties uh but
and of course you know she seems
incredibly able a young woman uh the
question you know but you're tested in
government but I think the fundamental
thing there's a number of able people in
the SMP I mean if s p is not short of
the political talent but of course we'll
Now find out if they can take that that
talent to the government but fundamental
thing for me is someone and there have
been a number of voices saying look it's
time to get a convention to get the
independence movement together and to
get the show meaningfully back in the
road we must leave it there thank you
very much
um this morning thank you very much